y llegamos al punto de presentar los
titulares de la prensa internacional
revista de prensa con rosa pérez más de
euros a bienvenida feliz miércoles para
ti vamos a dedicar toda esta sección de
revista de prensa uno de los editores
más conocidos del mundo estamos hablando
de julian assange no podría ser de otra
manera empezando hoy este proceso de
apelación por su extradición a estados
unidos y hemos adquirido empezar
señalando la página web que es la
oficial que recoge los apoyos contra la
extradición de julian assage a eeuu y
queríamos señalar como
organizaciones a firmantes de este
manifiesto entre estas organizaciones
figuran tanto asociaciones de derechos
por los derechos humanos como
asociaciones que abogan por la libertad
de prensa y de los periodistas pero
precisamente queríamos hacer hincapié en
este hecho porque recordemos que una de
las publicaciones más conocidas de
wikileaks fue la relativa a los crímenes
de guerra cometidos por el ejército
estadounidense tanto en irak como en
afganistán y que en ese momento para la
publicación de todos esos documentos
recordé filtrados por la ex militar
chelsea manning en ese momento wikileaks
julian assange se unió con grandes
cabeceras internacionales como el new
york times le monde der spiegel el país
o the gardian y ahora dejando a un lado
de gharyan que es una situación un poco
particular el resto de estas cabeceras
pues dan un poco la espalda no ya a esta
causa de liberación de julian assange lo
dejamos a un lado por ahora porque más
adelante vamos a salir con the gardian
pero antes vamos con liberación
cronología del caso assange en las
grandes fechas de una saga judicial no
rosas y titula este medio francés hace
un repaso de esta última década en que
ha ido aunque ha habido pues múltiples
giros de los acontecimientos si te
parece y vamos a ello raúl como no claro
que sí rosa vamos entonces a hablar de
lo que le había dicho empezamos con
diciembre 2010 no rosa exacto en
diciembre de 2010 de 2010 fue la primera
estancia de julian assange en prisión en
ese momento se encontraba en un
territorio británico y se entregó
voluntariamente a la policía porque
sobre él pesaba una orden de detención
internacional por las acusaciones de dos
mujeres suecas de violación unas
acusaciones que por otro lado él siempre
negó y que se archivaron en 2017 se
volvieron a abrir y se volvieron a
cerrar en 2019 pero en ese momento a
raíz de esta primera detención julian
assange quedó en libertad provisional
ahora vamos a junio 2012 inicio al
confinamiento forzado rosa exacto
estando bajo libertad provisional julian
assange se refugió en la embajada de
ecuador en londres donde acabó pasando
recordemos siete años ahí el entonces
presidente ecuatoriano rafael correa le
acabó otorgando ciudadanía ecuatoriana
pero más tarde su sucesor lenin moreno
acabó retirando está protección y lo
acabó en cierto modo entregando a las
autoridades británicas abril de 2019 un
giro inesperado exacto en ese momento la
policía británica entra en la embajada
en londres y lo acaba poniendo en
detención durante 50 semanas por haber
violado su libertad condicional
recordemos de 2012 mayo 2019 ofensiva
judicial estadounidense aquí es donde
cambian más las cosas para él de
wikileaks porque obama la administración
obama nunca había acusado a julian
assange con cargos de espionaje pero ya
bajo la administración ante donald trump
eeuu acusa a julián assange de 17 nuevos
delitos todos relacionados con la ley de
espionaje y es por eso que en eeuu si
finalmente es juzgado ahí porque se
aprueba su extradición podría ser
condenado a 175 años de prisión pasamos
a enero de este año 2021 en la
suspensión en ese momento pues la jueza
vanessa bright ser decide que la
extradición de julian assage a eeuu
podría comportar un riesgo de suicidio
para el fundador de wikileaks porque su
salud mental es muy débil y entonces
decide rechazar la extradición y vamos a
octubre de 2021 en este mes donde
estamos inicio del proceso de apelación
de eeuu que precisamente llegamos al día
de hoy efectivamente porque eeuu lo que
ha le da para que tenga lugar este
proceso de apelación es que la jueza dio
demasiada importancia al informe peritar
del médico y que no tuvo en cuenta
bloques julian assange ya había tenido
hijos estando en la embajada de ecuador
y que por lo tanto de ahí se deduce que
no estaba tan de precio ahora sigamos
con the garden como usted ya ha estado
adelantando tenemos dos artículos del
primero julian assange que espera del
proceso de apelación por la extradición
este artículo lo hizo en queens este
artículo pues se enseña las distintas
cosas de este proceso pero nos quedamos
con tres cuestiones y son principios de
hecho pues los tres hechos que señala
este artículo que han ocurrido desde que
fue rechazada la extradición a
principios de este año hasta ahora y que
podrían influir en la resolución de esta
apelación por un lugar por un lado es el
hecho de que eeuu promete ciertas
garantías de encarcelación de julian
assange como por ejemplo que podría
cumplir prisión en su nativa australia
pero cabe decir que eeuu también se
reserva el hecho de incumplir estas
garantías por otro lado que un
informante del fbi cambió su testigo y
por último esta investigación de yahoo
news que aquí sacamos de cómo le hacía
planeaba secuestrar e incluso donald
trump llegó a mencionar la posibilidad
de matar a julian assange's mientras
estaba refugiado finalizamos con el
segundo artículo de the gardian rosa
rápidamente para él con el invitado del
día está el amor y sobre su familia
secreta con julian assange es distinto a
cualquier persona que he conocido la
entrevista le hizo simón here in stone
este artículo básicamente lo que recoge
es la historia más humana la mujer de
julian assange explica cómo ha sido esta
relación mientras assange se encontraba
refugiado en la embajada y mientras
ahora está en prisión y como han podido
pues crear una familia bajo estas
circunstancias pues rosa gracias por
toda esta información esta revista de
prensa dedicada a julian assange el que
en el segundo juicio que inicia entonces
en londres muchísimas gracias nos vemos
más con mañana con más revista de prensa
nosotros vamos con nuestro primer
invitado el día
[Música]